R
THEIR HEAD. IN FACT TWENTY TWO
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS REPORT NOT
HAVING THE ABILITY TO PAY NEXT
MONTH'S RENT. AND MILLIONS WILL
BE FACED WITH EVICTIONS FOR
PAST MONTHS MISSED PAYMENTS
UNLESS CONGRESS ACTS. THIS IS A
POTENTIAL CATASTROPHE AND
THAT'S WHY SENATE DEMOCRATS
INCLUDING SENATOR WARNING VAN
HOLLAND AND SENATOR BROWN HAS
BEEN LEADING THE EFFORT BUT
COULDN'T BE WITH US TODAY BUT
IS LEADING EFFORTS ON THE
SENATE FLOOR ON THIS ISSUE
TOMORROW. AND OUR OTHER LEADERS
ON THE BANKING COMMITTEE AND
ELSEWHERE HAVE INTRODUCED BILLS
THAT WOULD PROVIDE AN EXTENSION
OF THE PROTECTIONS AND THE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE NECESSARILY
KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES. YOU
THROW SOMEONE OUT OF THEIR
HOMES. THEIR WHOLE LIFE GETS
DISRUPTED THEIR HEALTH CARE
THEIR HEALTH GETS WORSE THEIR
JOB OPPORTUNITIES GET WORSE
THEIR KIDS EDUCATIONAL
ABILITIES GET WORSE. HOUSING IS
FUNDAMENTAL AND IT HAS RIPPED
RIPPED BEEN RIPPED BY THIS
COVID CRISIS. LEADER MCCONNELL
AND SENATE REPUBLICANS HAVE IN
BLOCKED INTRODUCTION OF OUR
BILLS. REFUSING TO ACT ON THE
HOUSE PASS HEROES BILL PASSED
MORE THAN TWO MONTHS AGO. AND
THEY ASSISTED ONLY ON A THREE
MONTHS PAUSE WHILE THEY QUOTE
ASSESS THE CONDITIONS IN THE
COUNTRY AND THAT'S THEIR WORDS.
WELL THERE DID THE RING AND
DELAY. HAS BROUGHT US TO THIS
MOMENT WE'RE ABOUT TO SEE THESE
CRITICAL. PROTECTIONS EXPIRE IF
THEY HASN'T DETERRED. IF THEY
HAD SAT DOWN WITH US SPEAKER
PELOSI AND I SENT MCCONNELL
LETTER THREE WEEKS AGO AND
LET'S SAID LET'S STEP DOWN AND
TALK LET'S START SIMPLY SIT
DOWN AND TALKING. WE WOULDN'T
BE HERE. WE ALREADY HAD AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
BLACK AND BROWN FAMILIES BEFORE
THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC FORCED
PEOPLE OUT OF WORK AND LEADER
MCCONNELL WANTS TO SAY HOW
SHE'S GOING TO WATCH HOW THIS
PLAYS OUT. WELL IT SEEMS THAT
SENATE REPUBLICANS HAVE FINALLY
FELT THE HEAT AND NOW THEY'RE
SAYING WE SHOULD DO ANOTHER
BILL IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS. BUT
AFTER MONTHS OF WAITING SENATE
REPUBLICANS CAN'T EVEN AGREE ON
A PLAN. THERE IN TOTAL DISARRAY
IN CONFLICT WITH EACH OTHER AND
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THE PATH
FORWARD. ONE OF THE PRIORITIES
REPUBLICANS DO SEEM TO AGREE ON
IS WHAT LEADER MCCONNELL HAS
BEEN CLAMORING ABOUT FOR WEEKS.
THAT PROTECTING CORPORATIONS IS
THEIR NUMBER ONE PRIORITY ONE
IN FIVE RENTERS FACING EVICTION
AND MCCONNELL CANCEL THE TALKS
STOP TALKING ABOUT THE PANDEMIC
OF LAWSUITS. WE'RE HAVING IN A
LOOMING EVICTION CRISIS AND BY
ALL ACCOUNTS REPUBLICANS ARE
PREPARING TO BILL THAT WON'T
KEEP FAMILIES IN THEIR HOMES.
WE KNOW EVICTIONS AND UNPAID
BILLS CAN HAVE SERIOUS LONG
TERM EFFECTS ON HOUSEHOLDS AND
MORE THAN 40% OF BLACK AND
LATIN EX RENTERS REPORTER
UNLIKE UNLIKELY TO MAKE THE
RENT TO THE NEXT PAY PERIOD.
GETTING EVICTED CAN CAUSE
DAMAGE TO A FAMILY'S FINANCES
AND ADDICTION RECORDS TAKE
YEARS TO REPAIR. WITHOUT RENTAL
ASSISTANCE MORE PEOPLE WILL
EXPERIENCE HOUSING INSTABILITY
OR HOMELESSNESS PUTTING THEIR
HEALTH AND EVERYTHING ELSE AT
RISK. ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES HAVE TO
SAY TO THESE INDIVIDUALS YOU
LOSE YOUR JOB THROUGH NO FAULT
OF YOUR OWN THIS CRISIS YOU'RE
ABOUT TO BE EVICTED FROM YOUR
HOUSE AGAIN THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN OF YOUR OWN WHAT IS
MCCONNELL SAID. I WANT TO HELP
THE CORPORATE BIG BOYS ON K.
STREET BYE BYE WE DON'T NEED
YOUR- AWFUL. MANY OF THE PEOPLE
OUT OF THE AISLE YEAH I'M
ALWAYS AHEAD OF WHAT MY STAFF
RIGHTS ARE NOT ALWAYS SOMETIMES
IF WE PASS EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND EXTEND THE
EVICTIONS MORATORIUM WE HELP
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS PAY
THE BILLS. STAY IN THEIR HOMES
STABILIZE THE RENTAL MARKET.
AND KEEP UP HELP OWNERS KEEP UP
WITH THEIR PROPERTY TAXES AND
MORTGAGES SO ONCE AGAIN I SAY
TO LEADER MCCONNELL TO SENATE
REPUBLICANS WORK WITH US. TO
GET SOMETHING DONE. BEGIN
BIPARTISAN TALKS IT'S THE ONLY
WAY TO PASS A BILL. AND TO
PROVIDE PEOPLE THE HELP THEY
DESPERATELY NEED SENATE
DEMOCRATS WILL NOT STOP
FIGHTING SENATE FOREIGN. THANK
YOU MR LAWYER. SO I WANT TO
START BY. THANKING OUR LEADER
OF WHO HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
TRYING TO PUT TOGETHER HELP FOR
FAMILIES THAT ARE STRUGGLING
AND SENATOR VAN HOLLEN OF WE'VE
WORKED TOGETHER BECAUSE WE ARE
JUST DAYS AWAY FROM A HOUSING
CRISIS. THAT COULD BE PREVENTED
IF MITCH MCCONNELL STOP
STALLING IN THE SENATE TAX THIS
IS ABOUT OUR HEALTH OUR ECONOMY
AND OUR VALUES FORCING
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE OUT OF
THEIR HOMES DURING A PANDEMIC
WILL MAKE A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS WORSE. WIDESPREAD
HOUSING DISRUPTIONS WILL ALSO
AFFECT ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND
OTHERS WHO ARE KEEPING OUR
ECONOMY GOING AND A WAVE OF
EVICTIONS WILL HIT COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR THE HARDEST FURTHER
DEEPENING RACIAL INEQUITIES IN
OUR NATION. SO FIRST HOW BAD IS
THIS PROBLEM. MORE THAN THIRTY
PER OF ALL RENTERS SAY TODAY
THAT THEY HAVE LITTLE OR NO
CONFIDENCE THEY CAN MAKE THEIR-
MORE THAN 40% OF BLACK AND
LATIN NEXT RENTERS AREN'T SURE
IF THEY'LL BE ABLE TO MAKE
THEIR NEXT RENT PAYMENT. NEARLY
TWO THIRDS OF RENTERS WHO ARE
NOT CONFIDENT ABOUT MAKING
THEIR RANT EARN LESS THAN
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR. AND MORE THAN A QUARTER
OF BLACK AND LATIN NEXT RENTERS
COULDN'T PAY LAST MONTH'S RENT
OR HAD IT DEFERRED THINK ABOUT
THAT THAT'S ONE IN EVERY FOUR
BLACK OR LATINO RENTERS WHO ARE
ALREADY BEHIND ON THEIR RENT.
AND TO ADD TO THAT THE HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE THE NUMBER OF
WORKERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHO
HAVE HAD THEIR HOURS AND INCOME
CUT AND THE NUMBER OF SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE SHUTTERED.
AND MAY NEVER RE OPEN AND IT'S
CLEAR THAT THE NUMBER OF
OBJECTIONS WILL CONTINUE TO
RISE EXPERTS ARE PREDICTING AN
AVALANCHE OF OBJECTIONS IF WE
DON'T INSTITUTE NEW. ACTIONS
WE'RE ALREADY SEEING A RISE IN
INFECTIONS IN CITIES WHERE
LOCAL AFFECTION BANDS HAVE
LAPSED. THIS IS A CRISIS WE CAN
AVOID. STANDERFORD AND DENIAL
THE SENATE CAN STEP UP NOW AND
PREVENT THIS CATASTROPHE BEFORE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ARE FORCED
OUT OF THEIR HOMES.
REPRESENTATIVE JULIE GARCIA
KNIGHT INTRODUCED THE
PROTECTING RENTERS FROM
ADDICTIONS AND FEES ACT THIS
BILL PROTECTS RENTERS FROM
LOSING THEIR HOUSING IF THEY
LOSE THEIR JOB OR HAVE THEIR
HOURS CUT DURING THIS CRISIS
AND CAN'T MAKE THEIR HOUSING
PAYMENTS. THE BILL EXTENDS THE
FEDERAL VISION MORATORIUM TO
LAST ONE YEAR INSTEAD OF
EXPIRING THIS WEEK THAT MEANS
THAT RENTERS WOULD BE PROTECTED
UNTIL MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. IT ALSO MAKES THE MOVE
CORY UNIVERSAL EVERY WINTER
WILL BE PROTECTED AND EVERY
RENTER WILL KNOW THAT THEY ARE
PROTECTED THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
RENTERS OFTEN DON'T KNOW IF
THEY'RE COVERED BY THE FEDERAL
MORATORIUM. AND THEY ARE STILL
GETTING EVICTED. OUR BILL ALSO
MAKE SURE THAT RENTERS DON'T
GET HIT WITH HIGH FEES OR
PENALTIES IF THEY NEED A FEW
EXTRA MONTHS TO PAY THE RENT.
WE ALSO NEED SENATOR BROWN'S
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
BILL WHICH WOULD HELP RENTERS
MAKE PAYMENTS THAT THEY'VE
MISSED OR FUTURE RENT PAYMENTS.
SO THEY CAN REMAIN STABLE THE
HOUSE AND LANDLORDS CAN GET
THEIR PAYMENTS. FAILING TO PUT
A SAFEGUARD IN PLACE TO KEEP
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES IS MOST
LIKELY TO HARM THE MOST
VULNERABLE AMERICANS AND TO
HARM COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE ACT NOW WE
CANNOT DELAY ANY LONGER. AND
WITH THAT I WILL TURN THIS
OVER. TO SENATOR VAN HOLLEN
WHEN HE- IT'S ALL YOURS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR WARREN
AND TWO LEADER SHOW MORE THANK
YOU FOR ALL YOUR FOCUS ON
PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST AT RISK
RIGHT NOW IN OUR COUNTRY- AND
LARGELY BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
ACTION- WE'VE SEEN FROM SENATE
MIKE CENTER MCCONNELL AND
SENATE REPUBLICANS OUT TO
SANBORN THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS AND EVERYTHING ELSE
YOU'RE DOING. DRESS THE ISSUES.
BOTH MY COLLEAGUES THE SEN THE
CLOCK IS TICKING. THE SECONDS
ARE WINDING DOWN IN TWO DAYS
THE FEDERAL PROTECTIONS
BLOCKING ADDICTIONS WILL EXPIRE.
SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR THE
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WHO WERE
AT HOME STRETCHING TO MAKE ENDS
MEET. IT MEANS THERE RISK IN
FACT MILLIONS OF AMERICANS ARE
NOW AT RISK OF EVICTION. UHHUH.
UHHUH. UHHUH YEAH. UHHUH. UHHUH
UHHUH. UHHUH YOU KNOW. UHHUH.
UHHUH UHHUH UHHUH DONALD. IF
YOU LOOK AUND THE COUNTRY
THIS IS A HUMAN CATASTROPHE IN
THE MAKING. AND THE REAL OF
TRAGEDY HERE IS IT'S A 100%
AVOIDABLE. IF WE WERE TO TAKE
ACTION I INSTEAD OF ACTION-
SENATOR MCCONNELL I LISTEN TO
HIS COMMENTS ON THE FLOOR IN
THE SENATE THE OTHER DAY HE
NEVER MENTIONED. UHHUH. ON THE
OTHER HAND. UHHUH UHHUH. IN
FACT IT WAS OVER TWO MONTHS
AGO- THAT SENATOR WARREN AND
HIGH CENTER SCHUMER AND OTHERS
JOINED SHERROD BROWN IN
INTRODUCING THE EMERGENCY
RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND RENTAL
MARKET STABILIZATION ACT A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS.
LEGISLATION IS IN THE HEROES
ACT. INSTALLATION IS IN THE
HEROES THAT. WHICH ALSO WAS
PASSED MORE THAN TWO MONTHS AGO
SO HERE WE ARE COUNTING DOWN
THE MINUTES. WE SHOULD NEVER
HAVE BEEN AT THIS POINT WHERE
MILLIONS OF AMERICAN FAMILIES.
SEVENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
HOMEBUILDERS ASSISTANCE FUND TO
HELP HOMEOWNERS PAY THEIR
MORTGAGES AND KEEP A ROOF OVER
THEIR HEAD SO ASSISTANCE FOR
HOMEOWNERS AND ASSISTANCE
DESPERATELY NEEDED FOR RENTERS.
THAT WAS TWO MONTHS AGO. FOR
GOD SAKES IT IS GROSS
NEGLIGENCE IF WE DON'T GET THIS
DONE NOW AND HELP OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS IN THE- THANK YOU.
BOTH OF MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
HEARTFELT AND ARTICULATE
COMMENTS WILL TAKE QUESTIONS A
FEW QUESTIONS YES MA'AM. WHILE
YOU HAVE ME. IF PASSED. BUT FOR
THE FACT MATTER YES. AFTER WE
JUST LIVE WE DID NOT GET INTO
NEGOTIATION IT WAS NOT ON THEIR
LIST IT WAS ON OUR LIST. COULD
NOT GO ON FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE. THERE THANK YOU FOR
BREAKING. THANK. I WAS
WONDERING WHAT YOUR- IT'S- WE
HAVE A HEALTH CRISIS AN
ECONOMIC CRISIS AND A CRISIS IN
OUR VALUES BEARING DOWN UPON US
WITH MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ABOUT
TO LOSE THEIR HOUSING AND ALL
LEADER MCCONNELL WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT IS HOW TO PROTECT GIANT
CORPORATIONS THAT TELLS US
WHERE IS VALUE STARTED ALSO
TELLS US HOW WRONG HE IS PEOPLE
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY IN BLUE
STATES AND RED STATES NEED
PROTECTION NEED HELP AND LEADER
MCCONNELL LEADS TO HEAR FROM.
ALL OF THEM. YES OKAY I
COULDN'T HEAR YOU WANT TO SEE
BILL TEXT YES. ONE OF THE TOP
LINE GARTH YOU THINK THAT
THERE'S A STARTING POINT WELL
THE DEVIL IS IN THE DETAILS.
THEY DON'T TELL US WHAT THEY
WANT WHAT DO THEY WANT TO DO ON
EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE HELLO HOW
MUCH ARE THEY GOING TO CUT WHAT
ARE THEY GOING TO DO FOR
SCHOOLS NO NO YOU CAN'T
NEGOTIATE UNTIL YOU HAVE A
DETAILED PROPOSAL AND
PARTICULAR WILL START. AND
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF THE
FACT THAT THEY'RE NOT UNIFIED
WE ASKED THEM YESTERDAY IS THIS
GOING TO BE SOMETHING THAT THE
PRESIDENT AND THE SET BOOK IN.
FOR WELL WE CAN'T PERSONAL GOES
WITH REPUBLICANS AND TO GO.
WITH THE- THAT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE. ALL OF THAT. INFORMATION
PERFECT AND THINGS LIKE THAT
BUT DON'T SEEM TO BE A MOM
THEIR PRIORITY RIGHT NOW. BASED
ON WHAT WE ARE SEEING
REPUBLICAN BILL FOR YOU INSTEAD
EVEN HAVE A SINGLE THE SCOPE OF
THE PROPER DON'T. THEY DO NOT
HAVE THE VIEW OF THE SCOPE WHEN
MITCH MCCONNELL SAYS A MONTH
AGO WHEN TWENTY MILLION PEOPLE
ARE AT WORK TWENTY FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE ARE AT WORK THAT
MILLIONS OF BUSINESSES ARE
GOING UNDER LET'S ASSESS THE
SITUATION. THAT SAYS THEY'RE
OUT OF TOUCH. THERE'S SO IN
LOCKSTEP. TO DONALD TRUMP.
WHO'S ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS
PROBABLY THE REASON THE CRISIS
IS WORSE AS BAD AS IT IS. AND
SO IN FRAUD BY THE BUSINESS
LEADERSHIP WHICH CARES ABOUT
PROTECTING THEMSELVES FROM ALL
LIABILITY AND HIS BILL THERE IS
WAY OVER THE TOP- THEY'RE OUT
OF TOUCH THIS IS THE GREATEST
ECONOMIC CRISIS IN SEVENTY FIVE
YEARS THE GREATEST GROWTH
HEALTH CRISIS IN A HUNDRED
YEARS MCCONNELL GOES TO THE
FLOOR TODAY DOESN'T MENTION
THEM. AND TALKS ABOUT THE NEW
YORK TIMES AND CANCEL CULTURE
WELL THEY WANT TO DO IS FEED ME
TO THE RIGHT WING. RED MEAT.
OKAY THANK YOU EVER WE WANT ONE
MORE GUY HAD. YES YOU MAY.
THEREFORE MEANS FOR PROVIDING
ELECTION. INDUSTRY PROTEK YES
PROBABLY IF THAT'S NOT PART OF
IT SENATE BILL HEARING THINGS
LIKE CONGRESS TO PASS SOMETHING
TO LOOK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR
US TO KEEP IT IN THIS BILL AND
IT'S ONE OF OUR VERY HIGH
PRIORITIES. OKAY THANKS
EVERYBODY. THE PRODUCT. YEAH
RIGHT YEAH YOU ARE AND WHERE. I.
AFTER. LOCAL NEED HELP YEAH.
MAJORITY